the reality of it is having a very high
VO2 max being incredibly strong that's
going to do more for your lifespan and
health span than any piece of technology
or biohacking or manipulation of gut
biome or any other thing that people are
talking about I mean it's just not even
within the same zip code and you don't
need a lot of technology to do those
things you just need to put in the work
Patriots Yeah welcome to the show thank
you very much Chris would you say that
you have a unique or different
perspective when it comes to longevity
uh I don't know that's an interesting
question uh
yeah maybe in some ways I do I suppose
it seems to me that you're focusing on
not just lifespan but also Health span
as well not just physical health
emotional health mental health that more
holistic view seems to be
different to me
yeah and also I think kind of a somewhat
low-tech approach as well
um and I'm completely interested in you
know fascinated by obsessed with all the
high-tech stuff and the you know the
science that hopefully will come through
in the in the coming decades but I
you know maybe going back to my
background in in Risk Management I
really think everyone should always be
hedging everything they're doing so you
know to just assume that we're going to
come up with some
amazing technological breakthrough
that's going to you know start to defy
aging while not doing all of the things
that we can do with the technology that
exists today strikes me as unwise what's
that background in Risk Management
um I after I left my first stint in
medicine in 2006 I went to work for the
consulting firm McKinsey and Company and
though I was recruited there to do
health care I ultimately uh wound up in
the risk practice because my background
in math so uh I yeah I was doing you
know credit risk and uh cool stuff like
that all right and how does that inform
the way that you show up for your work
now
um I think it's essential right I think
I think everybody should be trained in
some understanding of risk everyone
should be trained in probability
statistics uh you know that's to me the
much more important stuff in mathematics
um and I I think that understanding how
to think about uh symmetric and
asymmetric risk understanding expected
value thinking about how to hedge risk
all those things are you know important
not just in you know thinking through
financial instruments where banks are
constantly making mistakes anyway but as
you think about your own life so I'll
give you a very silly example so uh two
weeks ago a friend said hey you want to
come you know skiing you know he's going
to go to this amazing place and Ski and
I said no he's like how do you not want
to do this and I was like well I don't
personally get enough pleasure from
skiing to justify the downside right so
the upside for me to go skiing with you
is this much the downside is this much
but that's my decision that doesn't mean
you shouldn't go skiing right because
for him the upside is probably much
larger and maybe he's a much better
skier than I am so his downside is much
less but it's thinking through simple
things like that every decision I make I
sort of put through that Matrix
that makes a lot of sense I'm interested
by this low-tech approach that you've
mentioned and I I keep on bringing this
up a mutual friend Andrew huberman uh
yourself it has really been at sort of
the Forefront I think and Kelly
starrette's new uh new book
um
he's almost sort of stripping things
back a little bit uh there was a
movement you know 10 years ago this sort
of Advent the absolute like Frontier of
the biohacking Quantified Self and it
really seems like that's not being
reversed but being taken back to
um a much more simple set of rules for
people to follow
yeah look I think they're not mutually
exclusive and I'm certainly no stranger
to all of those things and I probably
still do things that most people would
consider excessive when it comes to you
know tracking things and monitoring
things and incorporating technology into
what I do
but the reality of it is you know having
a very high VO2 max being incredibly
strong that's going to do more for your
lifespan and health span than any piece
of technology or biohacking or
manipulation of gut biome or any other
thing that people are talking about I
mean it's just not even within the same
zip code and you don't need a lot of
technology to do those things you you
just need to put in the work well it
seems to me that one of the longest
levers is compliance on whatever the
program is that you're going to do and
one of the problems that I found
certainly I struggled tracking macros
right I've always struggled tracking
macros so for me learning what intuitive
eating felt like actually meant that I
adhered to my diet more effectively than
setting the bar for compliance so high
that I just constantly failed and then I
didn't get any motivation from doing it
and I feel like that is a little
microcosm for tons and tons and tons of
ways where the bar has been set too high
for people to actually access these
protocols yeah everybody's got to figure
out the system that works for them I
think using nutrition as an example so
um
you know as I talk about in the book
there's basically three ways to go about
reducing intake so if you're over
nourished which is the kind of way I
describe people that have too much body
fat especially in places where you don't
want it right so it's not really the
subcutaneous fat we're worried about
it's the visceral fat it's the
intramuscular fat it's the
peripancreatic fat perinephric fat all
of those things that are metabolically
destructive so not the Cosmetic fat that
actually has no metabolic um consequence
so let's assume you established that a
person needs to you know me I need to
lose I need to reduce energy intake I
can do it by calorie counting or
tracking my macros I can do it by
dietary restriction by sort of
identifying things within the diet that
I don't want to eat and limiting them or
I can do it via time restriction just
narrowing the window down in which I eat
each of those has its pros and cons but
what matters is that you figure out what
kind of works for you so for me
personally dietary restriction has
always produced the best outcomes if I
simply pick certain boogeymans in the
diet and say I'm not going to eat those
things everything falls into line
whereas when I track macros which by the
way sometimes produces better results in
the short term it can be harder to
maintain conversely I have friends who
can track macros all day long every day
and they can do it automatically like
they don't have to be in it like that
one I'm not built like that in the
slightest and that's okay I mean again I
think the point is I I you know sort of
would want my patients for example to
try all three and figure out which one
works for them and as I always say like
you're better off being
7 out of 10 in performance but doing it
every single day then being 10 out of 10
some days 0 out of 10 other days and you
know that kind of cyclic performance
generally leads to worse outcomes over
the long run one of my friends Alex
mentioned to me the other day that most
people have a bucket of perhaps between
5 and 10 meals that they typically eat
and he said that one of the longest
levers when it comes to altering your
diet is to just look at those five to
ten meals even forget about everything
else it's like what do you eat the most
you probably have
for me it's like full recipes that I go
back to very consistently okay what's
that constituted of and how can you just
Tinker with that a little bit for it to
be closer to what your goals are I
thought holy [__] like that's such a
low-tech solution and yet in terms of
what it does does it grow any corn does
it actually work probably super
effective yeah that's one of the things
I enjoyed most about macro tracking when
I do it is you know the app I use which
is called carbon has you know and I'm
sure this is true of any of the apps now
they're all so much better than they
used to be 15 years ago when I started
trying to pay attention to this but you
basically put in your recipes so you're
not necessarily going to pre you know
populated things you're saying look when
I make an omelette I always do it the
same way it's eight egg whites it's four
yolks it's half a tablespoon of butter
doing it for 25 years the exact same way
every time so just click click click
click click and now I can know and
you're and you're absolutely right
there's probably no more than about six
things that are constituting eighty
percent of what I eat
talk to me about the difference between
slow death and long death ah okay so
um I mean as the name suggests it really
comes down to the rate of time between
when the onset of the illness takes
place and when you demise so if you
think about the greatest successes in
medicine our current medical system what
I call medicine 2.0 medicine 2.0 is
remarkably successful in treating fast
death
so
um when you think about trauma when you
think about a person who's you know
driving down the street uh car hits
another car and you know they suffer a
significant injury that 100 years ago
would have killed them we now have you
know remarkable capacity to save lives
in that situation infectious diseases of
course would be the poster child for
this up again up until 150 years ago we
stood no chance against uh most
infections and today you know some of
the most devastating bacteria barely you
know touch the surface and and by the
way viruses that once you know wiped out
civilizations we can now vaccinate
against and all these things so we've
effectively doubled human lifespan uh
going from about 40 to 80 years by
treating fast death
so big win for medicine 2.0
um the problem is we haven't really made
much progress against slow death so slow
death is what most people think of when
they actually think of death now when
you think of cardiovascular disease
cerebral vascular disease cancer
neurodegenerative disease metabolic
disease those are slow deaths even when
a person drops dead suddenly of a heart
attack right a person who's been
asymptomatic their whole life and drop
dead suddenly of a heart attack that
disease was killing them for 30 years
so unfortunately we just haven't made
much progress there and as I argue
that's where we have to make progress
that that has to be the transition if we
want to be serious about longevity why
is that not a priority currently
I don't think it's not a priority I
think we just have the wrong strategy so
um if you have the wrong strategy you
will fail and I would argue that we
don't have the right strategy for
addressing those problems so it's not
due to a lack of trying I think we've
been trying very hard to eradicate slow
death
and I would argue that the fact that
we've had such little success given the
enormous resources that have been put in
both financially and simply sheer effort
I think is proof positive that we need a
different approach we're going to go
through a lot of insights today that
people can apply to their lives
before we even get into that how should
someone think about building a framework
of how they can take the tactics that we
talk about today and actually use them
as we mentioned at the very start
compliance adherence you can have the
best strategy in the world if you don't
end up applying it it means nothing what
is your best advice on how people can
form a framework of tools that they can
actually use
well I think you have to start with the
objective uh so so everything I talk
about it I've always talked about this
way or at least you know for more than a
decade and I certainly have written the
book through this lens which is you go
from objective to strategy to tactics so
we always want to start with the
objective and I do think it's worth
being clear for any individual what
their objective is and I take a lot of
time with patients going through this so
um you know when you go to your doctor
that's not a common question what is
your objective and again it's not the
fault of the doctor I think it's the
fault of this system the system isn't
really set up to ask that question the
setup the system is more set up to kind
of play a bit of whack-a-mole is there a
problem right now is there a symptom
right now that I need to address but if
you're trying to play this sort of long
game you have to work backwards and say
okay
what do you want to be true at the end
of your life and the the framework that
I use for that is called the marginal
decade so the marginal decade is the
last decade of your life everyone will
have a marginal decade and that's not a
pleasant thought for many of us to think
about right I don't love thinking about
the fact that I'm going to have a
marginal decade but I will now you never
know the day you enter your marginal
decade
um but many people know when they are in
it
and the question then becomes what do
You Want To Be True in that decade
so let's play the game with you
how old are you Chris 35 okay so let's
assume that you know fate will smile on
you and you know God forbid you're not
going to have some premature death you
know you're not going to die in a car
accident next week or be stricken with
cancer in you know 10 years or something
like that
so let's just assume your marginal
decade is kind of the ninth to Tenth
decade of your life
what do You Want To Be True in that
decade
I would like to still be able to move
without assistance what kind of moving
uh I would love to be able to still walk
okay uh I would love to be I'm adored
dogs so being able to take the dog for a
walk being able to throw the ball a
bigger dog
golden retriever okay is that a big dog
yeah big for a 90 year old yeah okay
that's okay okay you can be ambitious
here I am ambitious yeah big golden
retriever okay
um
I was gonna be able to walk a golden
retriever yep how far
30 minutes a day okay yep uh maybe twice
a day if I could at best Hills or no
Hills uh not so fussed about hills okay
Hills can Hills can go but do you want
to live in a house that's got uh a
balcony okay so would need to be able to
go up and down stairs okay
um would love to still be able to pick
up grandchildren I have no idea whether
that's realistic at 90 years old but
that would be something I'd love to do
pick them up from the floor from a crib
okay
um
would love to have still a good quality
of sleep
um
and would love to be able to
have sex at 90 yep not something I've
considered good question let's say yes
let's say yes I'm still going at 90.
okay
um
and probably most importantly above all
of this is still have
proper cognitive function like still I I
value the quality of my thoughts more
than anything on the planet
um I still want to be able to learn I
still want to be able to satisfy my
curiosity you know if I was still able
to have conversations like this at 90
that would be just fantastic to me uh I
assume you don't want to be in pain that
would be good okay
so again we could drill into this a lot
further but I think what would emerge
and by the way this isn't this is a
valuable exercise because I don't think
a lot of people do this
um but I I think everybody needs to do
this and needs to go really far down the
rabbit hole and what you'll realize is
um by the way everything you've said is
totally reasonable like I have some
people when you play this game with them
you know the first thing they say is I
want to be heli skiing when I'm 90 and
it's like I'm not going to tell you
that's not possible but like that that's
the first thing you would say is a
little odd right but everything you're
saying is is achievable but is
challenging
so for example walking a golden
retriever
um at the age of 35 you don't even have
to think about it
but if you actually look at the force
that's in that leash and the amount of
balance and strength and lower leg
variability you need to not fall over
when that's happening
by the time you're in your 70s that's
going to be very difficult so you have
to build up an enormous Reserve in those
capacities today to cope with and
anticipate the inevitable decline that's
going to come in all of those so
so that's that's how you start you start
with the objective you reverse engineer
what the implication of each objective
is and you you know you you we
understand pretty well what the decline
of those properties looks like I need to
stop you that how realistic is it for
some male in his 90s to still be able to
have sex without any assistance well it
depends how you define assistance I
think the use of like phosphodus Trace
Inhibitors is probably going to be
required what's that like a drug like
Viagra or Seattle understood
um but otherwise I think it is realistic
um but again like think about what that
comes down to so a big part of that is
going to come down to your microvascular
system
so there's a reason that you know having
type 2 diabetes having atherosclerosis
is an enormous cause of impotence
it's not affecting your brain what it's
affecting is microvasculature the blood
flow of the penis so there's a there's
an argument for being very metabolically
healthy I mean I see this even in
patients who are in their 50s and 60s
who at one point are completely
dependent on drugs like Cialis and then
you get them metabolically healthy and
all of a sudden they're like oh I don't
need this anymore I wonder how many men
who aren't that concerned about getting
overweight who aren't that concerned
about losing a foot but if you tell them
that penis would stop working that would
be the final motivation for them to look
after that diet whatever it takes Okay
so we've got uh objective yep then we
have to think about what the strategy is
right and this is where I think
um
it's very complicated in this problem is
this where people get lost I think so I
think this is the step that most people
just skip all together and go right to
the tactics so they say okay I hear you
on objectives now tell me how to eat how
to exercise how to sleep Etc
um and I think you can't skip this
bucket and there's a reason that those
like chapters in the book that are
devoted to this
um
if you're playing
um if you're if you're trying if you're
asking questions that are
straightforward you don't really need a
strategy so if you said to me
Peter my objective right now is not to
get a sunburn
we don't need a major strategy like it's
relatively straight we can go straight
to tactics you're going to avoid the sun
altogether if you need to be in the sun
you're going to wear long sleeves and a
hat and you're going to wear sunscreen
and blah blah blah and it's it's pretty
straightforward but when you say my
objective is to live 10 years longer
than I otherwise would and do so at a
much higher function as evidenced by
that list of things you just said
well I can't just jump to tactics
they're not obvious so instead I have to
go through a whole bunch of indirect
measures because I don't have what I
really want right what I really want is
I'd love to be able to rely on the gold
standard which is randomized controlled
experiments that would give me the
answer
for reasons that are self-evident and
obvious and not worth explaining we
don't have randomized controlled
experiments that answer all the
questions that pertain to taking a 35
year old and setting him up to be the
best 95 year old
so we have to have an option b and
option b really rests on a whole bunch
of other pillars of strategic Insight so
one of those things is what are the
inferences we can make from
observational data of long-lived
well-functioned humans so looking at the
centenarians for example who we very
quickly figure out are genetically
gifted so they're they're they're their
superpower was picking the right parents
but we can still learn a lot from them
uh we'll put that aside for a moment the
other thing we can look at is short-term
human studies that don't cover the hard
outcome such as the full duration of
your life but cover certain things so
for example there might be hard outcome
studies that look at heart disease or
stroke or heart outcomes that look at
performance and functional metrics such
as strength resilience and things like
that we then look at animal literature
or non-human literature I think to be
more accurate that looks at the full
duration outcome so I think we can look
at some of those animal studies and get
a pretty good sense of what's affecting
lifespan and health span but we have to
be careful with it like we do with
everything and that we we want to be
very thoughtful that we're not just sort
of zeroing in on one model so this is
again where where we look at things that
favor lots of models so you know
something that's consistent across mice
and worms and flies and dogs is much
more interesting than something that is
only going to work in one Mouse model in
one person's lab
then we want to look at mechanistic
studies so how can we understand for
example the benefits of exercise when we
look at the cellular level when we
understand them you know when we look at
proteomic metabolomic changes of
exercise and how do you know what do
those things tell us as an example about
say exercise or sleep restriction or
dietary restriction and then the final
tool that I think we look at in our
strategy bucket is mendelian
randomization so sometimes
you actually let nature do the
randomized controlled experiment for you
so mendelian randomizations are very
elegant types of studies where when you
can find genes that are responsible for
phenotypes of interest you can ask the
question as nature shuffles those genes
do we establish causality by the outcome
so when you put all five of those
together that's how you start to Cobble
together what your tactics are and
that's the final piece of it so what are
your tactics you basically have five
domains you have all things that pertain
to what you eat all things that pertain
to how you exercise and move how you
sleep all the drugs molecules
supplements hormones that you could
possibly take and then all the you know
call it the bucket of things that you
would do to manage emotional and mental
health
when you break it down like that
longevity seems very simple that you
have these five key areas that you're
focused on
where are people focusing their
attention in your opinion when it comes
to both Health span and lifespan
longevity
that have the shortest levers but people
are giving undue attention to
yeah that's such a great question I I
think what's what I find funny is that
everybody and I'm sure I'm not sure I
know I've been guilty of this myself
it's
it's very tempting to just focus on your
favorite thing like there was a point in
time where virtually all of my attention
was focused on nutrition
like I really felt that nutrition was
the the Alpha and the Omega of this
entire equation and all you had to do
was sort of eat a certain way and
everything was going to work itself out
um
obviously the medical establishment is
hyper focused on the the medicine side
of this as evidenced by the fact that's
the only thing we learned in medical
school and residency right it's not like
anybody taught you how to administer
exercise or nutrition even if you knew
that those things mattered you had no
education in how to actually do anything
about it it would sort of be like an
oncologist who knows chemotherapy is
good
but doesn't know anything else like
doesn't know which chemotherapy or what
dose or what schedule or what biomarkers
to use to track the progress of the
chemotherapy in the um you know in the
tumor as it regresses so
um
so each each entity I think just kind of
has their own expertise
um you know where I stand today I would
say
a lot of people are kind of majoring in
the minor and minoring with the major
when it comes to nutrition is sort of a
belief that I have I think once you get
beyond the real fundamentals of energy
balance and protein intake I honestly
think a lot of people are spending too
much time
um thinking about the finer details of
it
um and and and the evidence at least at
this point in time is not really there
in an overwhelming way to say that it
matters a whole heck of a lot once you
achieve that in other words there are
multiple different ways to achieve
energy balance to achieve you know
adequate distribution of fats
macronutrients and things like that but
the belief system that I once had and
that I think many others have that you
know
this exact ratio of omega-6 to omega-3
is what's essential
if that's true it's not based on any
evidence as of this time
you've mentioned the protein intake very
important what are your thoughts on this
current movement at the moment which is
people
avoiding and sometimes demonizing meat
consumption because of activating the
mtor pathway
yeah I think there's a bit of a
confusion between chronic activation of
the mtor pathway and acute Activation so
we do need mtor to be active sometimes
right I mean mtor is the most important
amino acid sensor we have in our body
and if we want to be in a uh in an
anabolic State at some times which we do
it's going to have to be activated right
in fact I would argue that the three
most important amino acids leucine
lysine methionine will mtor is the
leucine sensor right I mean leucine and
mtor were sort of made for each other
this is very different from the
metabolically ill person whose mtor
level is probably chronically elevated
there's also an issue with tissue
specificity and again part of the
challenge here is in humans we have no
way of measuring this so we can measure
this stuff in mice you can sort of look
at mtor activation and muscle versus
liver versus some other tissue in humans
we can't do any of this we don't have
what David sabatini refers to as an mtor
integrator a signal integrator so the
sort of the way that hemoglobin A1c is
an integrating function of average
glucose right it integrates glucose
level over the previous three months
roughly we don't have a tool like that
to measure mtor activity so
um again I think that the the belief
that we need to limit amino acids to
limit mtor activity is is kind of a
backwards way to think about it what
that's really going to do is create a
situation of sarcopenia which uh muscle
like loss of muscle as we age okay yeah
surely though if people are consuming
three to four servings of
25 to 50 grams of protein per day
is that not just going to continue to
just Spike M toward does that not end up
netting out at mtol just being elevated
throughout the day not necessarily I
mean you have to remember the the
um the duration that you know free amino
acids stay in your circulation is pretty
low
um you're also probably still spending
12 to at least 14 hours a day when
you're not eating
right so even so so so I'm someone who
probably takes a lot of effort to
consume you know
1.8 to 2 grams of protein per kilogram
of body weight and that's going to be
spread out over three to four meals but
there's probably still 14 hours a day
when I'm not eating anything and during
that period of time those amino acid
levels are going to be really low
I heard about you doing some very
extreme fasts over the last few years
talk to me about those yeah I don't do
that anymore but I used to do a lot of
fasting for many years I would you know
do a seven to ten day fast quarterly and
a three-day fast monthly
that's intense
that seems intense yeah me you know I'm
someone that's done intermittent fasting
I sat down with David Sinclair
four and a half years ago I think in his
office at Harvard uh and you know when
David first came onto the scene which
was the first time I'd really really
heard intermittent fasting as being
pushed as a longevity lever uh I thought
this is great like you know it's
something that I can do it's for the
lazy Among Us it actually makes eating
food easier because we've managed to
reword skipping breakfast as doing
intermittent fasting but
I found it incredibly difficult to blend
staying fit
staying muscular and doing intermittent
fasting I really really struggled to
make that work
um what have you got first off why have
you changed your approach to
intermittent fasting I know that you've
gained a ton of muscle recently
um and how have you worked in blending
your understanding of intermittent
fasting and its positive benefits with
the fact that you want to look good feel
good perform well
yeah so again I still think going back
to kind of what are the three ways that
you can reduce caloric intake you can
you can calorie restrict directly so
just track and reduce globally you can
dietary restrict which is pick certain
elements within the diet carbs fat
whatever restrict or you can time
restrict create a smaller and smaller
window in which to eat
um the biggest drawback of that final
strategy which again is a viable
strategy but the biggest drawback of it
in my opinion is the the reduction in
protein intake
so this has been borne out in the
literature so we've seen we've seen
clinical trials that have documented
this that first and foremost the time
restricted feeding within that 24-hour
period doesn't seem to produce any
benefits above the caloric restriction
that it brings that's a very important
caveat okay it's just meaning there is
nothing magical about the time
restriction beyond the calories that are
being restricted wow okay so the hunger
signal that people get which is those of
us that have taken like the Sinclair red
pill this is a signal that I'm hungry
this is homies it's happening this is
discomfort this is good for me
has no different impact than small
amounts of satiation throughout the day
with there is nothing that has been
measured or documented in any clinical
trial that suggests that that is
beneficial over the clerk restriction in
other words if you're going to eat 2 000
calories spread out over 12 hours or
you're going to eat 2 000 calories
spread out over six hours where you're
you know calorie you know your time
restricted feeding for 18 hours
we're not seeing any difference wow now
and now that's not here's what's
interesting that's often not what
happens
so what more likely happens is the
person who calorie restricts
um has an easier time Believe It or Not
maintaining muscle mass than the person
who time restricts
why
probably for two reasons uh although
this hasn't been fully teased out in the
in the data because they're not tracking
it this closely but my
my impression is that when you time
restrict you're just less likely to eat
as much protein
and secondly as you kind of alluded to
earlier
it's a delicate balance to get the right
amount of amino acids into the muscles
you can't have too much and you can't
have too little
so what you don't want to do is waste
for lack of a better word your amino
acids down a gluconeogenic pathway where
they're basically being used as glucose
substrate what would cause that to
happen either too much or too little so
it wants too much and what's too little
yeah sort of 10 to 20 grams of protein
the liver is going to preferentially
take that and use it as glucose and
anything over about 50 grams the liver
is going to say I'm going to take that
excess and also make it glucose so let's
just say your number is 180 grams of
protein per day eating 18 servings of 10
grams a day not going to achieve optimal
results having one serving of 180 also
not going I've tried both yeah yeah
um so that person really probably ought
to be doing four servings of 45. right
so you're saying for most people it
seems like roughly a sweet spot is 25 to
50 grams per serving exactly right so in
this regard and that that time
restricted feeding guy has a really hard
time doing that if he's going to be
deliberate about that how big is the gap
when does a feeding window stop great
question probably about three or four
hours so it's basically impossible
for the time restricted feeding person
unless they're willing to eat protein
outside of their window
right okay which if you are a dogmatic
around if you're dogmatic it becomes
very difficult correct but if you're if
you understand that there and what we do
with our patients who who want to do
time restricted feeding because I think
it's the easiest one to do yep like I
would agree it's the easiest one
conceptually to do it's the easiest one
to be compliant with so what we would
say is look it's just about the calories
so I still want you to have a low
calorie protein shake in the morning
where you're going to have 200 calories
of a protein shake that's basically just
protein some you know cashew milk and a
few frozen berries
um but at least you got that protein
dose in yep the other thing that I would
say leads to what we experience
clinically as a lot of people losing
muscle mass when they do this is a lot
of people exercise in the morning but
their feeding window is in the evening
so now they're creating a little bit of
a gap especially if they're untrained
it's less less of an issue in a trained
individual but in an untrained
individual we do see some benefits to
having the amino acids uh restored in
Greater proximity to the training
how worried should we be about
artificial sweeteners
I don't know uh would be the short
answer I I think that this is another
one of those things where uh
boy people really love to demonize these
things
um but if you if you really just want to
look at the facts let's talk about facts
right so aspartame which is the original
kind of the OG sweetener uh everybody
loves to demonize aspartame or
NutraSweet but the reality of it is if
there is toxicity to it it's probably
impossible to measure at regular doses
this is a substance that at least the
last time I checked had more data on it
from a safety perspective than any other
molecule tested by the FDA you're
kidding no it's it's just because again
it's been around since the 1960s right
so does that mean that if you
consume the equivalent of 12 cans of
diet soda a day it's safe probably not
but we don't know right so
um where do I think these sweeteners
potentially reek the most Havoc
you know one is I I think that they
probably increase your appetite for
sugar anyway so if you're if you're
consuming them in an effort to avoid
sugar
um you have to be just mindful of the
fact that am I robbing Peter to pay Paul
um if you really want to eliminate sugar
as one of your dietary strategies uh you
might just be better off reducing sweet
things altogether and what you'll
discover because I've gone I've done
this myself I've had periods in my life
where I've been you know very dogmatic
about restricting sugar I'm not that
dogmatic about it these days right but
when I have been you know one of the
things I noticed was how unbelievably
sweet things are that I used to not
think were that sweet like berries you
know like you know raspberries aren't
generally thought of as the sweetest
thing in the world but when you
completely eliminate artificial
sweeteners and regular sweeteners you
know after a few months berries become
insanely sweet you know 85 chocolate
becomes mind-bogglingly sweet as opposed
to what most people would think but it's
kind of bitter
um you know there was a recent study
published that looked at uh one
particular sweetener erythritol and
um it was a pretty poorly done study
um but look it asked some interesting
questions right which is you know is a
metabolite of this potentially
atherogenic I was androgenic uh would it
lead to or cause atherosclerosis what's
that cardiovascular disease sort of the
the the inflammatory disease of the
coronary arteries and other arteries
um
again I I think the data are are pretty
underwhelming that artificial sweeteners
are harmful but I also think there's
probably a class of differences between
them so my personal favorite of all of
them is something called allulose
um allulose is it's basically natural it
is an enantiomer of fructose meaning
it's a molecule that's almost identical
to fructose with one very minor
structural change
what's unique about it is it has in my
opinion the best taste because the thing
I don't like about artificial sweeteners
is I just don't like the taste I
actually like the taste of sugar I don't
like the taste of you know saccharin I
don't really like the taste of aspartame
I certainly don't like the taste of
stevia I mean that to me makes me want
to vomit but alulose has the same taste
the same mouth feel as sugar and the
only drawback is it's only 70 is sweet
which is not a real drawback because you
could always dose it up if you want it
also has the added benefit of it appears
to actually reduce blood glucose a
little bit it appears to have an effect
where it pulls glucose
um into the kidney and like basically
increases the filtration glomerular
filtration of glucose so it slightly
lowers glucose not as potently as
something called a an sglt2 inhibitor
which is a class of drug that does that
but it's it's very interesting
nonetheless so
um you know I guess if I were thinking
about how I would consume it I would
probably consume more allulose than
other things but unfortunately it's
still not that prevalent in Foods you
have to you have to just buy the
allulose itself so if I'm making
something I'll use allulose in it what I
like about this framing is it gets to
one of the reasons why doing a
randomized control trial for diet stuff
is so hard because how are you going to
be able to control for the psychological
training that having a sweet thing even
if it is a zero calorie sweetening even
if it's a zero calorie sweet thing with
no Downstream risks to your body unless
you take it at insane dosages
how are you going to be able to control
for what that does psychologically to
people's expectations of the sweetness
of their foods of the frequency of
having sweet things throughout their
diet
um yeah I think that's a really nice
little microcosm there one of the I'm
wearing a wood band at the moment
um some people are drowning in data now
right we've gone from a world where we
knew nothing to where some people know a
lot but I would guess on average that
even people who care about the health
and fitness are still mostly not wearing
a Tracker they're still mostly not
getting blood panels done they're still
mostly not going and getting a full body
MRI scan etc etc
what are the most important metrics for
someone who is completely uh
unindoctrinated into the world of
looking at Vital Signs within their body
what are the most important metrics for
people to be looking at
well I mean again I I have a pretty long
list on that because we're we're holding
ourselves to a pretty high bar
um so the way I think about this is what
are the inputs to what what I call the
longevity risk assessment
so
um there were basically about seven or
eight things that are a threat to your
length of life and quality of life we've
talked about them already right so
cardiovascular disease cerebrovascular
disease cancer neurodegenerative disease
Orthopedic injury emotional distress
misery like all those things right
so how do we know how you're stacking up
on all of those things what are the
inputs to do them so yeah blood tests
family history selective genetic testing
colonoscopy MRI liquid biopsy VO2 max
Test Zone 2 test dexa scan I mean the
list is long and I I think in our Matrix
we have over 40 things that go into that
or over 40 inputs that go into our risk
assessment and then that risk assessment
leads to outputs so what do you do in
response to the the ranking of risk
based on those things okay run the
Matrix go and do those things and then
let's come back and measure and do again
so it's hard for me to say what the most
important is because it really comes
down to an individual so if an
individual shows up and they have a
significant family history of
cardiovascular disease well look a CT
angiogram is going to be very important
and a blood test that's measuring LP
little a lipids and APO B is essential
because you have to know which you know
which of these things is responsible for
that you know certainly you know a
continuous blood pressure monitor or at
the at a minimum you know we would have
patients checking their blood pressure
at home two to three times a day for a
month again super low Tech right you
might think how is that interesting well
it's enormously interesting because
blood pressure
is one of the biggest risk factors for
Alzheimer's disease and cardiovascular
disease so again people are obsessed
with things like you know their sleep
data but don't forget the really you
know you know less sexy stuff that we
could have measured forever such as
blood pressure but knowing how to
measure blood pressure accurately is
important and I I think you know
undiagnosed hypertension is an epidemic
in this country what do people get wrong
when measuring blood pressure the first
thing they get wrong is they don't
measure it but assuming they do measure
it
um they're not stationary for five
minutes before they measure it they
don't have the cuff on correctly they
don't have their arm in the right
position you know if your arm is too low
or too high you're going to get an
inaccurate reading your arm really needs
to be the cuff needs to be right at the
level of your heart
um you you have to pay very close
attention to where the cuff tells you to
put it you know you want to be about an
inch above the break in your arm and
there's a a good cuff will tell you
where the how to line it up with the
brachial artery in your arm
you don't want to have just had coffee
right before you do it you don't want to
be sitting like I am with your legs
crossed your legs need to be uncrossed
so there's a whole protocol for how to
do this and there's a very good study
called the Sprint study that that really
established the the measurement standard
for how to establish
um a proper measurement for blood
reading which was you know five minutes
sitting stationary without doing
anything stimulating measurement five
minutes of you know doing nothing again
repeat measurement five minutes repeat
measurement so 15 minutes to get three
measurements taking the average that's a
blood pressure now we don't ask our
patients to do that we ask them to do it
once but two to three times a day so you
should even out any inconsistencies yeah
and you'll also notice trends like are
you normal in the mornings but elevated
in the afternoons and uh you know the
data are really clear that anything
above 120 over 80 has long-term risk
associated with it and so when we see
people that have an elevated blood
pressure we want to make sure we're
addressing that and there's lots of ways
to address it before you have to go down
the pharmacologic pack but if you have
to go down that path you're much better
off going down to protect your kidneys
your brain and your heart what
is good and what is bad about different
types of cuffs or automatic cuffs okay
yeah so the gold standard is of course a
manual cuff so having an actual person
yeah who's who's got a stethoscope on
the brachial artery and measuring your
blood pressure the problem is unless
you're you know you have like for me
that's what I do typically because my
wife can measure my blood pressure even
I can measure my own blood pressure so
marry someone who is trained for taking
blood pressure that's what you're saying
but the automated cuffs are pretty good
um in me they run high so across the
board automatic automated cuffs tend to
run 10 to 15 millimeters per Mercury
high systolically and they're accurate
diastolically that's just a glitch I
have never been able to come up with a
compelling explanation for why but I'm
not unique in this
um I we do see this uh in a number of
people where the the gold standard runs
lower than the than the cuff
um
so the challenge of doing an a manual
cuff when you're at your doctor's office
is the challenge of having your blood
pressure checked at the doctor's office
for some people it produces this
syndrome called white coat hypertension
where my mom's got that yeah they just
you you sort of get you know and by the
way the other thing is most the time you
walk into the doctor's office they don't
even adhere to this principle right five
minutes yeah yeah you sort of run in
from the parking lot run up the flight
of stairs sit down in the waiting room
last time you had a coffee yeah yeah so
so again I'm I think that blood pressure
is a very difficult thing to to
accurately glean in the doctor's office
for all those reasons and that's why I
just think everybody should you know buy
one I I don't have any affiliation with
any company that makes these things but
there's a brand that I like called Omron
Omron that's the one we tell our
patients to get you can get these things
on Amazon and
um
what are the most common
uh lifestyle interventions let's say
that someone does get toward that 120
over 80. where should they go first what
do you think exercise is is a big one
aerobic exercise is an enormous way to
lower blood pressure as is weight loss
so weight loss is going to be mostly
driven by nutrition and then aerobic
exercise and and sleep so because I
track my blood pressure pretty regularly
um two of the most obvious things that
show up when I'm not well slept is you
know higher blood glucose and higher
blood pressure
I went to uh Medellin I went to
bioaccelerator down there and got a ton
of stem cells for a week medellin's at
altitude and they were coming in and
testing my blood pressure three four
times a day using that and I had a nurse
doing it which was nice you know to have
uh the sense that A team's there for
your health that was I really enjoyed
that part and felt like I was being
cared for uh but at altitude and I'm a
heavy guy uh at altitude my blood
pressure was not happy
um so I came back and I thought I really
need to I really need to make a change
here I really need to because even if it
is at altitude et cetera Etc I was in
there with uh Al Jermaine Sterling who
is
um the current UFC 135 champ uh and yes
Elite athlete yes best in the world
literally what he does but he wasn't
struggling and I figured I I probably
could do with making a change here so
what's the what's the altitude there I
don't know I don't know High higher than
higher than I'm used to I presume um and
you're getting stem cells for what so
they reached out and suggested that I go
and get a procedure I've got two bulging
discs L3 L4 and L5 S1 that's been an
issue for a while although it is I've
managed to get it to a very manageable
place now which I'm very happy with
um a little bit of rotator cuff it just
bro injuries you know like sometimes my
knees are a little bit achy I had a full
Achilles Detachment playing Cricket a
couple of years ago most British way
that you can do it
um so I went in and I had a 110 million
uh through IV two separate ones uh
oxygen chamber twice two sessions of
that a bunch of vitamin IVs Two
intra-articular Shots into the shoulder
uh quadriceps tendon above and below the
patella and then straight into the
Achilles and then a intradiscal
injection into L3 L4
and uh every faster joint as well done
my lumbar spine under general for the
spine stuff which was great under
nothing for the local injections which
were spicy but um that was seven
eight seven eight weeks ago now uh and
three months is around about the the
time when this stuff's supposed to kick
in so I'm very much looking forward to
seeing uh how that works I enjoyed
psychologically it was neutral
physically slightly difficult
um the sort of uh is it cytokine
information response is something to
behold
um for the next 24 hours it felt like
anyone that's had Doms after a
three-month break from the gym
imagine that kind of stiffness but
exclusively in the tendons of the places
that have been touched oh God it was so
localized and so I was laughing in for
the next day as I sort of totted around
like a robot um it was very interesting
experience
what about
Health metrics that people are
overlooking so we've mentioned you know
even the stuff that you've given there
in terms of Top Line probably VO2 max is
your HIV your resting heart rate your
blood blah blah blah is there something
that most people well think about how
many what how many people listening to
us today do you think know their VO2 max
very few yeah very few yet there is no
metric that I am aware of that is more
highly correlated with the length of a
person's life than their VO2 max wow
why not even close why why that
particular metric well there's probably
two things going on right one it
actually does matter a lot it's an
amazing proxy for health
if you think about have you had a VO2
max test done recently not recently I
had one done last one was probably four
years ago okay so think about how
miserable it is right like what is it
testing right it is testing your maximal
consumption of oxygen well to get to
that level we are stressing you to the
highest degree possible it's it it is as
its name suggests it is a maximal VO2
max test so the higher that number is
the more oxygen your muscles can utilize
the more fit you are the healthier you
are the more capacity you have uh to
avoid illness and
um so I think there's the biological
reason for it I think the other reason
for it as opposed to say your Zone 2
threshold which I think would probably
be equally predictive
um is
that it's a metric that is so ubiquitous
it's very standardized it's easy to test
for conceptually not necessarily
physically and so you have a metric that
we can easily capture
so it's for example it's better than
like a deadlift
right in deadlift there's variability of
form there's too much risk of people
getting hurt it would be a harder metric
to track
so you have this metric that you can
track and then the having a high number
tells you something about the person
right to have that number you must be to
have a high number you must be
exercising a lot and we know the
benefits of exercising a lot
right the person who has a VO2 max at
the top two percent of their age
I mean by definition they're doing a lot
of exercise and exercise has more
benefit than probably any other single
intervention we can do so again it's I
throw that out there because I say like
yeah we know those things we know
exercise matters but when it comes right
down to it most people don't know if
they're fit enough
most people don't know their VO2 max
most people don't know their almi
appendicular lean mass index they don't
actually know how much muscle mass they
have they don't know where they stack up
for other people their age and sex and
yet that's also a highly highly
predictive metric of how long you're
going to live
they don't actually know how strong they
are they don't know if they're in the
top 25 percent of their age or sex for
strength
so I think it just comes kind of back
down to the basics but like we have to
know these things if we you know what
gets measured gets managed and if you if
you're not measuring these things
there's I don't know what you're
managing
what is the best protocol that you have
found for improving VO2 max in terms of
training uh it's two things right so so
you want to think of the the the way I
think of cardio respiratory Fitness is
it's a pyramid so you have a base to a
pyramid and you have a peak to the
pyramid and you want the biggest
possible pyramid so the area of the
pyramid is your total cardiorespiratory
but also wide exactly so the width of
the pyramid is your zone two that's your
sort of aerobic efficiency metric so if
you and your VO2 max is the height of
the pyramid so if you want a high
pyramid you also need a high base so you
have to do training that widens the base
and raises the peak so the base widening
training is what we call zone two
training so again there's lots of ways
to do that but the simplest way to do it
is to train at an rpe that barely allows
you to maintain a conversation so
um
the way I describe it to people is I do
my zone two on a bike uh on a trainer
indoors right I'm listening to podcasts
and audio books it's a it's a pace of
training where I'm mostly able to
breathe through my nose
um but that just speaks to the fact that
I have pretty good Airways a better
metric is
if my wife comes in and talks to me or
if the phone rings and it's important
and I pick it up I can carry on a
conversation but it's strained the
person absolutely knows I'm exercising
they're doing something fusion
um but I can speak if it if I'm at the
point where I can't speak I'm outside of
zone two I'm into zone three what uh
heart rate is that have you got any idea
for you yeah for me it's uh typically a
heart rate in the high 130s okay that's
a little higher than I would have
guessed but yeah you might speak but
cardiovascular well but it also varies
day by day so yesterday I was having
such a lousy day uh probably because I
didn't sleep really well that that ended
up being a heart rate of about 131 to
132. so it varies I've had it days where
it's as low as 130 and days where it's
as high as 145. how old are you 50.
wow so that is that's still very fit I'm
gonna guess that'll speak to the fitness
that you've got
um well I think it just speaks to the
bigger point I think is that it just
speaks to kind of the variability you
have in heart rate between individuals
um but then to train the peak of the
pyramid I think the most efficient way
to do that is kind of so so VO2 max
training is maximized between three and
eight minute intervals so if an interval
you will train VO2 max if you're doing
something harder than that if you're
only doing something you can hold for 30
seconds or one minute that will still
give VO2 max benefit but not nearly as
much as if you can push it closer to
three four five minutes Etc so
for me personally I'm I mostly do that
at four minutes so I'll do four minutes
very hard four minutes of recovery four
minutes very hard four minutes of
recovery so I do those also on a bike
usually and I'll do those outside on a
hill
cycling this yeah so there's a hill near
my house that is
up it's a it's a just a straight Hill
that's not so steep like meaning I'm in
the saddle I don't have to be out of
this I'm just in the saddle looking at
my power meter and my heart rate and
just
going very very hard for four minutes
getting to the top feeling like I want
to puke going back down doing it again
just repeat repeat two sets no I'll
typically do four to six
okay how often per week I just do that
once a week okay and that seems to be
well again it's remember what I'm
training for now when I was training as
a cyclist I was doing those types of
workouts three times a week
and they were much longer and much more
grueling but again I was optimizing for
a much broader array of Fitness but for
today for all I'm doing is no I'm just
you know I'm just trying to be a good
I'm just trying to be fit as a person
not as an athlete so yeah once a week of
doing a very hard VO2 max set four times
a week doing those lesser zone two sets
how long on zone two uh 45 to 60 Minutes
a session okay so you're looking at what
180 to 240 minutes cumulatively correct
so I'm basically doing four to five
weeks of cardio training a week which is
you know depends who you ask like first
by my historical standards that's very
very low obviously for some people that
would still be considered a lot
um I I think
you know I think it would be crazy not
to want to capture the benefits of
something like exercise
um so we do you know sort of sit down
with everybody and say okay how much
time are you willing to put into
exercise and then that's how we sort of
think about how to allocate time across
all Endeavors strength
um you know stability aerobic efficiency
Peak aerobic power we we do take kind of
a portfolio approach to that but
starting through the lens of how much
time are you willing to put into it so
someone like me who's willing to put in
10 to 12 hours a week that's you know
the role of the bases as much as you
want absolutely yeah okay so you've got
four pillars strength stability VO2 max
zone two yep
strength and stability talk to us about
that
um so strength is probably the easier
one for people to understand
um you know that's basically your
ability to generate Force
um and of course within strength you
have different you know different areas
of strength so I don't do a lot of
maximal stuff anymore so in other words
I'm rarely
If Ever I don't think I really ever go
below three reps so the the heaviest I
will go is five reps stuff so I'll do
you know I'll do dead lifts 35 ish
UMR because you're not doing it but I
can sort of predict it because I do use
a velocity tracker so if you've seen
these yeah yeah the BuzzFeed things yeah
yeah so I do measure bar speed
um so I can have a prediction of it I
can have a prediction of one RM
um
but yeah usually I'm sort of in the 5 to
15 rep range when I'm training so I'm
basically but but what I'm always trying
to do is make sure I'm somewhere between
zero and two reps in reserve
so that's I'm really training off reps
in reserve okay that's my overarching
principle of training is so so even if
I'm at five I'm probably training to one
to two rep in reserve
if I'm at 15 I'm still one to two reps
in reserve there's the body builders out
there that want to do supersets and drop
sets to failure that are tearing their
hair out at the moment
yeah I'm sure and again I there are
absolutely sets where I do go to failure
but the truth of it is it's very hard to
go to failure all the time I I think I
think if people are being brutally
honest with themselves like they still
had another one or two reps left every
time yeah I don't I I mean I
I I know what it's like to go to failure
um and you don't you you only have so
many of those matches every day
um so I don't even try to play that game
I just sort of say like
I know I've learned that I've got if I
stop now there's only two more I would
get before I would violate my form so
badly that I would either injure myself
or you know just effective transcending
ego lifting is uh one of the most
difficult things that you can do forget
about the consistency and all of that
it's transcending ego lifting
um
strength formulating a strength protocol
across the week what are you
prioritizing you're prioritizing large
lifts are you prioritizing session
length etc etc yeah it first of all
there's quite a bit of
um variability in my in my training
um but generally I'm doing four days a
week and not generally I'm always doing
four days a week and it's two days lower
body two days upper body now I I used to
I've for Years also done three days of
mixed longer sessions but I prefer what
I'm doing now I prefer doing two lower
body days two upper body days and
uh yeah I prioritize big lifts and I'm
sort of working on like so today I had
24 working sets uh of of upper body uh
you know on Monday I had
18 sets of lower body 18 working sets of
lower body
and probably on Friday it'll be a little
bit more volume it'll probably be 22 to
24 sets of lower body uh working in that
five to Fifteen yes uh which is Ish Opie
eight e eight eight eight and a half
yeah yeah sometimes maybe as little as
seven on some things especially if
you've had the [__] night sleep yeah the
night before yeah
um
what when you're looking at movements
for instance what was your session this
morning can you remember in terms of
exercises yeah so uh
uh I did floor presses uh dumbbells yep
yep I did
um pull Downs I did incline press
I did row
I did
um
um like incline curl
uh overhead tricep extension
and um and then a preacher curl you know
it's not a true preacher bench but
hanging over a bench doing a preacher to
create the same angle yep and then uh
laying tricep extension and then always
in between them I'm doing stability work
so we didn't come to stability but I'm
doing I do two dedicated days of
stability a week so Tuesday Thursday I
do a full dedicated hour of stability
training and then on the off days it's
not Tuesday Thursday I'm getting in at
least 20 minutes of stability per day on
on either side of the exercise like
throughout the workout so the stuff that
we've gone through so far
the Jim Bros will still understand what
cardio is the cardio Bros will still
understand what lifting is
nobody understands what balance training
is yeah no one understands what what are
the principles behind this no one's ever
thought about stability training before
uh how do you integrate it into your
workouts and then also what does a
dedicated session look like
yeah it's very difficult to explain
um it's actually I think it was the
hardest chapter in the book to write
truthfully
um because
it's
it's not it's it's hard enough to show
people in videos or to have friends over
who want to work out with me and put
them through the exercises that's
actually very difficult
um so
you know I lead with an analogy in the
book where I talk about the difference
between streetcars and track cars
because I'm a car nut and I being on the
racetrack is probably one of my favorite
things to do and
um so so the analogy I give is is this
which is
um
if you took if you take a street car
with very high horsepower and you put it
on track and you let it race against the
track car which is lighter less
horsepower typically for a given engine
size or for a given class size slick
tires on it which one's going to be
faster I mean it's no comparison right
the track car rips the streetcar into
Oblivion even though by the way the
streetcar will go faster in a straight
line
um so the example that I use in the book
is a real example I compare at the time
this is you know seven or eight years
ago my streetcar at the time was like a
uh an actually a modified e92 M3 so nice
I've modified it changed all the airflow
that thing was putting out
475 horsepower big German based yep and
at the time my track car was a spec E30
M3
I'm sorry not even an M3 just a spec E30
okay right but everything's stripped out
roll cage is in stiff as hell
165 horsepower
engines in it oh this is the stock
engine
yeah it's a six in line right okay yeah
yeah so so you've got the this the stock
165 horsepower engine it's very light
the car weighs like probably 2 400
pounds versus the M3s 3 400 pounds m3's
got street tires on it this one's I'm
running you know probably Hankook slicks
on it but to your point the chassis
stiff as a button suspension super stiff
and yeah I was going faster in the
straightaways in the M3 but my lap time
was two seconds faster which on a track
is might as well be a day yep
um in the spec E30
and of course what does it come down to
it's cornering speed what does cornering
Speed come down to it comes down to of
the 165 paltry horsepower in that engine
every little bit of it is making it
where it belongs remember what is the
name of the game in driving a race car
it's all about friction it's all about
power loss it's all about transmitting
what's happening in the crankshaft to
the tire tire to the street that's it
you only have four points of contact
with the outside world nothing else
matters and so again we're not talking
about aerodynamics because these aren't
Aero cars right so in the in the
streetcar first of all I have much more
slippage at the tires
because I've got I'm not running slicks
secondly the chassis is so loose right
swallowing all over the place I've got
all this all this energy loss with
energy leaking out of that car not
making it to the surface of the track
it's like having laxity in a joint
that's right so every time you're
hurting your knee you're hurting your
elbow something's hurting that's an
energy leak
so again even if one doesn't care about
performance just from an injury
perspective this is something we want to
avoid we want to avoid it and again my
introduction to stability only came the
hard way it's not like I was born out of
the womb realizing this was an important
thing I mean I had to go through
horrible injuries to finally arrive at
this place where I said you know I'm
tired of being in pain I'm tired of the
fact that my elbow hurts when I do
pull-ups and you know oh like half the
time I deadlift or squat my back hurts
you know my SI joint hurts the next day
like I was just kind of tired of that
and then I got very fortunate and that I
landed
um in the in the company of a guy named
who I write about in the book briefly
his name is Michael stromsness and he's
a practitioner of something called DNS
Dynamic neuromuscular stabilization and
the very first time I met him you know
at the time I was like
my main complaint was uh basically my
right SI joint and my right elbow I had
tennis elbow having never played tennis
and he said all right you know take your
shirt off and hop up on the bar and do
some Pull-Ups so I I did and rattled off
you know 15 pull-ups or something which
I could do easily at the time
um and he's like oh that's horrible like
those are those are and by the way these
are good form pull-ups I'm not doing
like bro pull-ups where I'm like jerking
up and down I'm doing like full
extension up like everything perfect and
he's like yeah you have no capacity to
control your scapula so your scapula is
winged and in doing so you are
transmitting all of that Force into your
elbows
you cannot retract your scapula you
don't have the control you don't have
the stability in the scapula so you're
leaking energy through your scapula in
your arm so to make a very long story
short that that which started in 2017
um just took me so far down the rabbit
hole of not just DNS but other other
schools of thought I would later go on
to meet someone named Beth Lewis through
Michael who
um you know has has her own expertise
around
um other other disciplines and we
basically just started piece by piece
rebuilding my movements and by the way
that meant spending a year not doing
pull-ups and not dead lifting as I
re-learned how to how to align my body
again and so today I'll still spend two
days a week working with a guy here in
Austin named Kyler Brown who's amazing
um working on just dedicated DNS things
and again if you watched the exercises I
was doing you would be thinking what is
he doing
you know like why is he doing you know
why is he in these baby positions like
moving in these odd ways but a lot of
what DNS is based on is the idea that up
until we were about two years old we all
moved almost perfectly
um most of our movement patterns that
are corrupt which we all have as adults
only started to kick in once we were
about two
uh maybe one but but generally about two
so so there's a very predictable you
know neuromuscular set of or sequence of
movements that are genetically
programmed into us the ability you know
the way a child reaches for something
the way a child rolls the way a child
stands the way a child you know gets
into a bare position all of these things
are basically hardwired into us and the
goal of this type of training is to
basically provide a software update on
the crappy software we've ins you know
we've we've overridden that system with
let's say someone doesn't live in Austin
doesn't have access to your very smart
friend there are lots of DNS
practitioners across the country but you
would advise doing this with instruction
I think so yes efficiently complex and
nuanced and I think DNS is
um is very difficult to learn
um I shouldn't say that I haven't tried
to learn it off you know videos and
online and there might be ways to do it
but but I think you know trying to find
a practitioner is a good way to start
um and then once you have it going it's
it's always great to to to you know
continue on your own and there's a lot
of stuff I do with my friend Kyler
that's not DNS I mean you know one of
the issues I've been having injury-wise
I have very flexible ankles I think a
lot of former swimmers do and so one of
the drawbacks of that is
when I do freaks I love doing box
step-ups we're both Cut From the Same
Cloth I knew that you were a massive fan
of these they're my favorite movement
for the lower body I absolutely love I
love doing them in all regards I love
doing them very very heavy I love doing
them very very slowly all these things
well because my ankles are so flexible
and I can really really dorsiflex I have
a tendency sometimes when I'm because
like as you know when you're when you
want to do a step up the real key to it
is pre-loading the glute and the ham
correct not bouncing off the floor
that's right so so to pre-load you want
to be able to shift forward and glide
the femur back that creates an enormous
stretch eccentric stretch so that that
front leg is loaded boom you pop up okay
well in doing so I often will drive my
knees so far over my toes because I have
the flexibility of my ankles but
sometimes I'll develop a little bit of
discomfort there in the front so one of
the things I'm working on with Kyler is
Soleus strengthening to actually
counteract that move movement bring it
back yeah and so the amazing exercises
that he has come up with for me to do
these you know to do solely a
strengthening which again you have to
you have to be very deliberate about
doing that it's easy to strengthen your
gastrox the Soleus requires more effort
I learned this intimately during my
Rehabilitation absolutely I overshot it
actually it was hilarious so um
this is not a good time to snap an
Achilles but during Cove it wasn't bad
um and I overshot it on my right leg
which is the one that snapped and I
ended up having to then work on my left
more aggressively to catch it up because
I'd ended up building up a calf that was
bigger I mean I learned so much man from
that the first thing was I had a 13-day
wait period because I was doing it on
the NHS although I managed to find uh
one of the top three surgeons in the
entirety of the UK through a friend who
was on the NHS to come and do my
reattachment which was really really
great it felt like being um fitted in at
the end of the day with a barber that
needs to do the haircut and I was
waiting around all day all day all day
and then it got to the very end and we
he had to run it back and I had to go
back tomorrow I've been fasted all day
because I was going to go into General
and think blah blah blah anyway
um
a bunch of the things that I learned
from that coming out the other side were
how important it is to be able to deal
with not just strength but plyo
especially for that ankle position but
what I'm thinking here when when you're
talking about your challenges with box
step ups there's a guy called Dr Eddie
Joe PhD on Instagram now he took a
massive Hiatus for like three years but
he did these really great breakdowns of
academic literature in infographics
which lend themselves to Instagram very
nicely and I'll never forget this one
from nearly four years ago I think and
there'd been a study done looking at
muscle fiber recruitment for glute
exercises and you know you look at the
glute Factory bum lab things for girls
that want big glutes or me that's
increasingly realized that my back gets
better the bigger that my bum gets
um and glute Bridge donkey Kickback side
raises all manner of Fantastical
exercises that that girls do and he'd
ranked them by uh the amount of muscle
fiber recruitment the top five exercises
were step UPS or step up variations it's
like Step Up
cross body step up like lateral step up
something something something and then
maybe hex bar deadlift was
in the sort of upper middle uh deadlift
another one and then you get down toward
like glute Bridge Kickback and it's at
25 and I think it's 95 on this
particular scale of this number would
Step Up So for anybody that wants to
improve like lower body power I just I
absolutely adore that movement and it's
so easy to do we
um you know in the first iteration of
writing the book I had intended to put
so much detail in about instruction on
like kind of the most important
movements in the end it was getting too
long so what I did is I ended up
creating videos for a handful of them
and one of them is the step up so
there's a pretty good video
um on this like the book will Point
people to where to go on our site to see
it and it's I just watched it yesterday
it's a pretty good instructional video
is it you doing it it's me doing it with
Beth and I talking through how to do a
step up cool uh weighted unweighted low
box High box the whole thing eccentric
concentric what are the pitfalls how do
you you know how do you unload the ribs
to you know you know do them me
correctly and all that stuff so
beautiful yeah
um going back to some of the other uh
we've spoken about sweeteners
what about vaping if you had a look at
any of the signs from vaping I I it's
kind of a little bit of a moral panic at
the moment if you look at certain areas
of the ancestral paleo worlds on the
internet uh what's your thoughts on
vaping and its potential let's come back
to kind of the risk reward Matrix right
so again I view everything through this
two by two so
what's the risk is it closer to getting
hit by a tricycle or getting hit by a
train and what's the reward is it
picking up a dollar or is it picking up
a gold coin
so
I think that the I don't think we have
sufficient data to say that it's picking
up that it's getting hit by a tricycle
um I don't think the industry is
standardized enough to be sure that what
is being inhaled is sufficiently clean
maybe it is maybe some companies are
better than others I mean we could talk
about that all day long but I'm not
personally willing to put my trust in
that in that market in that
infrastructure in those companies
whatsoever so so for me personally this
would be a no-brainer there's no upside
in it to me
what would you be concerned about going
into your body it's not just the
nicotine it's the stuff oh no first of
all nicotine I love like I'm all about
nicotine how do you use nicotine in a
safe way
um I would chew gum or I would use I use
like a lozenge or I ch um there's like
these little patches that you you know
kind of suck on Zen pouch what have you
found is your favorite brand for those
um
I'm blanking on the name of the brand
they come in a little round colorful
thing I don't remember the name of the
brand got you and you're using three
makes five makes
um unfortunately that's the maybe I
haven't bought in a while from these
guys I bought so many the first time by
accident that I'm still living off the
last two years worth I literally just
like an idiot accidentally bought 10
times more than like a prep up yeah so
um Unfortunately they only come in
sevens which is no way dude I would you
can't do it all at once that would be in
my mouth for 30 seconds and then I would
have to take it yeah yeah so I go in out
in out and out and out
um I think they have a four as well so
it's a little bit more manageable yeah
but truthfully like I think two
milligrams is sort of the right dose one
to two milligrams is probably the sweet
spot and then you don't need to think
about taking it in and out yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um so so no to be clear like the the the
nicotine is not the problem right uh
it's the it's just like with cigarettes
nicotine is not the problem with
cigarettes yes there's an addictive
component to it the problem is the
toxicity of the vehicle that's
delivering the nicotine in the form of
tobacco well with vaping I don't have
any sense of what's happening when you
have a heated metal filament that is
burning combustible products some of
which I may or may not be inhaling
through a filter like what I'm saying is
not that I know there's something wrong
with this but I'm saying I have no
confidence in that industry to regulate
itself or our regulatory agency to
regulate them and therefore
because I don't know where it is on the
risk parameter but I definitely don't
feel comfortable saying it's getting hit
by a tricycle it could be getting hit by
you know a small car it could be getting
hit by a train for all I know we you
know it's just an unknown and then you
know how would I justify it well unless
I felt that the reward Matrix was
picking up gold coins it just doesn't
justify it to me so
is that a moral panic I don't think so I
think it's just saying like what's the
risk reward trade-off for it Justified
skepticism perhaps uh another Revolution
that's going on at the moment which I've
been at the sort of front row seat of
has been alcohol and the reduction in
the consumption of alcohol I think
people realizing
it's no surprise that it's a a really
dangerous risk but people who considered
that one drink was okay that two glasses
of wine because this in Resveratrol
coming from the red grapes etc etc
um I was a club promoter for a very long
time so I was in the trenches partying
hard for all of my 20s which is why your
uh 90th to 100th year estimation I think
is unfortunately going to be a little
bit too generous but
I went sober for six months really loved
it
um most to do with the lifestyle changes
cognitive cognitive improvements uh what
it meant in terms of habit in terms of
consistency energy uh money time all
that stuff came back to drinking didn't
like it went back to sober for another
six months came back to drinking for a
couple of months didn't like it did a
thousand days sober uh I never had a an
issue with substances but just really
loved what it had done for me and you
know
five years hens six years hence now the
low and no movement seems to be really
really gaining speed
is that so why is it so surprising like
why is it that something that ostensibly
obviously wasn't that good for us is now
only just beginning to kind of
get some momentum of people thinking oh
maybe this thing that makes me feel like
a total pile of dog [__] the next day is
something that I shouldn't take all the
time I don't know I can't speak to it
the only thing I could speculate is that
with the uh with the rise of sleep
trackers I think you really have some
objective data on the downside and I
don't I don't think anybody who's worn a
whoop who doesn't look at their heart
rate variability pre and post alcohol
consumption or the fragmentation of
their sleep is not saying what the hell
it's insane why is it such an impact for
the unindoctrinated amongst us let's say
that you've got a heart rate variability
of 70. if you were to have two glasses
of beer or two small glasses of wine on
an evening finishing at nine or ten pm
and then go to sleep on the night it
wouldn't surprise me if from 70 your
heart rate variability is down in the
30s yeah or the 40s what is happening
inside of the body that's causing that
to happen so alcohol is metabolized
um into different elements but but one
of the metabolic byproducts of alcohol
is quite toxic and
um I suspect I don't know but I suspect
what's happening is the toxicity of that
is changing the autonomic nervous system
so in what you want what you want to be
doing when you're sleeping is in a
maximally parasympathetic State
um that the so-called rest and digest
State and that's really what heart rate
variability is measuring right heart
rate variability along with other things
such as heart rate itself and
temperature respiratory rate are proxies
for your autonomic nervous system and
anytime those things move in the wrong
direction so heart rate goes up heart
rate variability goes down respiratory
rate goes up temperature goes up all of
those things happen when you drink
that to me is a very strong signal that
something about the toxicity of the
metabolic byproduct of ethanol is
putting the body into more of a
fight-or-flight response as opposed to
arrest and digest response it it's so
hilarious that the thing that a lot of
people use and has been used for a long
time I can't get to sleep I'll have a
glass of whiskey uh isn't really aiding
with sleep it's just sedating people
yeah that's the Insidious thing about it
right is people confuse sedation
Consciousness and sleep and I I you know
I'd love to tell the glib anecdote right
which is like if I hit you over the head
with a baseball bat you would lie
motionless for 12 hours but of course
there's no confusion over the fact that
you are not sleeping and nothing about
that experience is good for your brain
or your body in terms of rest and
recovery so yes alcohol is very sedating
but it doesn't promote sleep in the way
that we know sleep Works in terms of its
stages and its functionality in terms of
healing let's say that no one has looked
at Alzheimer's or neurodegenerative
disease what do we need to know
the first thing I think everybody needs
to know uh you're talking about from a
personal risk standpoint or just
understanding the disease personal risk
okay yeah so the first thing I I you
know we want to know from all of our
patients is tell us your family history
right that you know there is a genetic
component to this disease so let's
understand what your susceptibility is
um would you ask them that ahead of just
saying go and get a genetic tester oh
absolutely yeah because the the I think
the family history is more telling than
the genetic test wow okay because
remember the genetic test we look at is
we look at the most common Gene which is
the gene that's easiest to test for
which is apoe there are a dozen other
genes that we look at but they're much
harder to sift for there aren't really
great commercial tests for them and God
knows if there's something lurking that
isn't part of this current Paradigm of
what we understand yeah exactly did it
show up yeah if it showed up yeah so so
right out of the gate we want to know is
is
um is dementia in your family if so what
type do we think it is so do we think
it's Alzheimer's dementia do we think
it's vascular dementia do we think it's
front to temporal lobe dementia do we
think it's Lewy Body dementia is there
Parkinson's disease when you think about
just comparing Parkinson's disease Lewy
Body dementia Alzheimer's disease those
are three types of neurodegenerative
diseases that are on a spectrum where
Alzheimer's is the is the most
cognitively destructive Parkinson's is
the most movement movement destructive
Lewy Body is taking bits of both of
their playbook right so Lewy Body is
destructive to both movement and
cognition well we want to understand
exactly what pattern you may or may not
be a part of we also want to understand
age of onset so
um tragically there there's a
fortunately very very rare but um you
know still unfortunately
prevalent form of early onset
Alzheimer's disease these are people who
are afflicted in their 40s and 50s is
that what Chris Scott no no he got he
realized something during that day yeah
Chris Chris learned that he has two
copies of the APO E4 Gene and the APO E4
Gene is the most common genetic uh you
know the most common Gene responsible
for Alzheimer's disease but not but it's
not early it's not early onset right
it's a late onset predisposition okay
the early onset ones are um called app
psen1 psen2
um so again those can be tested for we
don't normally test for those because
it's normally so Apparent from family
history uh of course now if we document
that we would of course test for it
tragically I think that's a variant of
Alzheimer's disease that is
um I think it's less clear how much you
can prevent lifestyle Independence right
whereas the one that Chris has and that
25 of the population has if they have
one copy of that Gene that's highly
amenable to prevention which really gets
to why we want to know this stuff
you want to know this stuff because one
sometimes that's the motivation people
need to take this seriously when they're
35 years old and young and
indestructible because that's the time
you want to actually act and secondly
there are certain things that we know
are even more important to people with
that genotype so it would factor into
what medications we might use to lower
cholesterol it might factor into how
much
omega-3 EPA and DHA we would want them
to take it might factor into other
choices we might make around nutrition
and even in people who are exercise time
limited it might factor into how we
prescribe exercise what are the biggest
prophylactics against mental degradation
over time
so I did recently did a podcast on this
um it's an AMA on my podcast that is 100
devoted to all interventions that
improve cognition And Delay the onset of
dementia and I sort of broke it down
into
here are the things for which there is
no ambiguity about the benefit
so enormous signal
I'm not going to talk much about them
because it's I'll give you you know the
basics on it and then I spent the entire
podcast talking about the gray stuff
where there's probably a benefit but
it's harder to quantify so you're asking
what are those things that I didn't
really talk about it's basically
exercise
um
uh lipid management
not having type 2 diabetes
and probably sleep
having adequate sleep those are those
are the No Regret moves that that have
enormous impact and it's probably in
that order
so it seems like looking at what we've
spoken about so far today and you
mentioned it earlier on you thought diet
was this unbelievably huge lever
it seems now that exercise is one of the
longest if not maybe the longest I think
it is that you're talking about I think
it is yeah I think the day certainly the
data would suggest that right so in
other words you go back to
so a hazard ratio is a very it's an
important tool in statistics to
understand the relative risk or benefit
of any intervention so a hazard ratio of
one means that this intervention has no
benefit and no harm a hazard ratio of
1.5
means this intervention is 50 percent
riskier than the Baseline a hazard ratio
of 0.75 means this intervention is 25
percent less risky right okay so
um when you just go off those numbers
what's the what's the hazard ratio of
smoking well it depends on the study but
it's about 1.4
so what that means is and that's for all
cause mortality so that means that if
you're if you compare a smoker to a
non-smoker all things equal at any point
in time that smoker is 40 more likely to
die in a given year than the non-smoker
it's devastating right if you look at
hypertension
it's about 1.2 1.21 so having high blood
pressure means you're about 20 to 21
more likely to die in a given year than
someone who's identical to you in every
way except they don't have high blood
pressure if you look at somebody with
you know atherosclerosis so Advanced
cardiovascular disease it's about 1.25
um if you look at somebody with
end-stage kidney disease so someone
who's on dialysis it's like
2.75 that means there are 175 percent
more likely to die in a given year than
someone who's not in end-stage renal
disease
so
now start comparing all of these other
interventions I'm talking about well
let's go back to the VO2 max if you take
somebody who's in the bottom 25 of
fitness
which by definition 25 of the population
are and you compare them to somebody
who's in the top two percent for their
age
it's a five
that has a ratio is five
so it means it's 400 percent difference
in mortality
if I take somebody who is in the bottom
quartile of strength and compare them to
the top quartile of strength it's about
three as a hazard ratio
so when you go through these metrics of
exercising or muscle mass or strength or
cardiorespiratory Fitness it just dwarfs
everything else including diabetes
including smoking so and again this
isn't a zero-sum game like the goal is
get as many things on your side as
possible be of normal weight don't have
diabetes be sleeping well don't smoke
but be strong as hell have a high VO2
max I mean you want you want to Stack
the odds as much in your favor as
possible there's no guarantee in life
and this there's still an enormous
stochastic random bad luck component to
life I could walk out of here and get
hit by a car but I'd like to control
what I can control
heart disease is the biggest killer on
the planet at the moment born on
why are our hearts so fragile
I mean actually I would argue they're
not right if you consider what your
heart is doing right you know it's like
this amazing organ that is
beating non-stop without any instruction
from you consciously and has this
remarkable capacity to respond to your
autonomic nervous system On Demand right
someone runs through this door and
startles us our heart rates are going to
Skyrocket instantly we don't even need
to tell it something bad is happening
right I you know you you go to you know
get stem cells at elevation your heart
rate knows to get jacked uh so so so so
so this this thing is in a remarkable
muscle
um but
it has
um it has a narrow blood supply
you know so
um
and it doesn't have a remarkable
capacity to revascularize itself that's
probably its biggest drawback
you know other muscles in our body uh
have in much easier time undergoing
angiogenesis
so if you know if you suffered kind of
uh you know an occlusion of of a blood
vessel a small blood vessel in your leg
it wouldn't cause as much trouble
because you'd have kind of an easier
time creating collateral flow around it
but in the heart that's that's that's
less the case and of course the stakes
are much higher you probably wouldn't
notice it if a you know
a silver dollar size patch of your quad
stopped working it wouldn't reek as much
Havoc as if an equal sized patch of your
left ventricle stopped working
um so the problem is that
Evolution didn't really care about
atherosclerosis that's that's really the
problem right so atherosclerosis is
driven by factors that Evolution wasn't
at all
caring about because they didn't
interfere with reproductive Fitness so
smoking high blood pressure and high APO
B are the main drivers of
atherosclerosis and none of those things
were on Evolution's radar in fact you
could argue
um High APO B for a period of our human
history would have been beneficial APO B
being the lipoprotein that wraps around
LDL and vldl would have played an
important role in a scarce nutrient
environment which we were in up until a
few hundred years ago
and today of course it creates a problem
right today those apob particles those
LDL particles are carrying cholesterol
into our artery walls and our immune
system which by the way is doing the
best job it can like the little train
that could is treating that as though
it's a foreign Invader and mounting an
enormous immune response and it's that
immune response it's actually
leading to the creation of plaque that
ultimately results in a heart attack so
when it comes to heart disease it seems
like there's two broad elements here one
would be restricting the things which
cause risk and the other would be
improving yourself from Baseline what
are the big buckets in either of those
you mentioned smoking smoking blood
pressure and APO B so if you just took
those three things off the table it's
very hard to imagine how you can get
atherosclerosis so if you don't smoke if
you maintain a blood pressure at or
below 120 over 80 and if your APO B is
maintained at the physiologic level that
kids have you can't get atherosclerosis
how does someone know about their ipob
simple blood test cost about 12 bucks
okay and how often do you need to get
that done uh I mean I probably check
mine three or four times a year I
probably check mine three times a year
um yeah and if it came back and said
this is high then you would try to ask
the question why is it high how much of
this is going to be fixable by diet how
much of this is going to be fixable
pharmacologically truthfully to get to
the levels that are necessary to
eradicate atherosclerosis for most
people does require pharmacologic
intervention this is probably in in my
opinion if antibiotics represent the
biggest win of medicine 2.0 uh
anti-lipid therapy would be the second
biggest win okay that's stopping the bad
yep improving the good for the hot yeah
so again exercise not surprising
um and probably more so the benefit on
cardio here you're probably going to see
more of a the data would certainly
suggest that cardio is the more
important exercise of the two but again
I always caution people you're not just
feeding your heart you got to worry
about your brain you got to worry about
your body so we're never going to get
into the to a cardio or strength
Paradigm it's and it's always going to
be and but just to be clear the cardio
training probably has a better impact on
the heart
um um
sleep
so uh lo you know poor sleep has
devastating impact on the heart probably
through sympathetic overtone uh
hypercortisolemia things like that so
stress becomes another thing that really
matters it's kind of again it's one of
these sort of fuzzy terms that kind of
seems like oh yeah yeah stress I'm sure
but but I think the data are very clear
that high levels of cortisol
um are are really damaging to coronary
arteries
um and then again nutrition kind of
factors in probably to the pharmacologic
strategy so there's no question that
um for you know if you're if you were
saying
what would be the most Draconian
nutrition step I could take to minimize
my lipids
um you could take that step but you're
probably creating three other problems
in its wake right so if you went on like
a 10 fat diet
you would probably drop your lipid
levels to you know very healthy levels
the problem is what other problems would
you how do hormones look yeah how do
your hormones look how does your muscle
mass all these other things and so what
you call it lifelike only having temps
on fat in your diet right so the way I
think about it is
when I can use so so if I can use
pharmacology to solve a problem without
creating another problem that's a far
better use case than using nutrition to
solve a problem that creates a whole
bunch of other problems because you can
be more targeted yep yep understood
that's interesting
what about motivation like what do you
think about
motivation because we're talking here
about all of these things that we could
do and should do and potentially need to
do but those are the competing goals
that people have got as well in here
what have you found given that you know
overwhelming number of things that you
get exposed to but anyway it'd be good
if I added this into my routine you
could get to the stage where there is no
life left in your life yeah
how do you map
your intervention threshold and then try
to stay adhering and compliant given all
of the stuff that there is to do
well I mean I think everything has a
season right so there's been periods of
my life when I've been far more
disciplined and far more regimented than
others and um
again I just I kind of always want to
remind myself that
I never want to be in the situation
where everything is off the rails so if
I'm really feeling stretched thin if I'm
really feeling like I can't do it all
then I have to start prioritizing then I
have to start you know if you're on a
Lifeboat and you can only take so many
things this is where it really matters
that you think about what you need and
so if
um
you know if if
for example when I was you know
finishing the book and under
you know unusual amounts of stress based
on the demands of the book the demands
of my practice the demands of the
podcast all these other things
I just made a very clear unilateral
decision like there's certain things I'm
not going to care about and one of them
is going to be eating like I'm going to
indulge and kind of eat whatever the
hell I want to eat but I'm not going to
compromise sleep or exercise because I
know that those two things Factor far
more into my productivity my cognitive
capacity and my mood truthfully and yeah
in an Ideal World I would be firing on
those cylinders plus eating perfectly
but I was like look sometimes I will
sometimes I won't and if my assistant
manages to be able to get me a great
salad for lunch today that's awesome but
if she can't and I feel and I'm starving
and I just want to go and have a bowl of
cereal soapy I'm just gonna have a bowl
of cereal like I'm not going to beat
myself up over this or Let It Bleed into
some other areas
and of course you know I hope that
that's not something that endures
forever
um and of course you know it doesn't you
know you just have to remember that
um
you got to remember why you're doing
this right so I think I don't know that
motivation is the right word I think
it's sort of purpose that that matters
um I don't really know what motivation
means I I at least for me personally I'm
sure for some people that word has
meaning for for me kind of purpose is
the thing that matters a more accurate
word for me to have used would have
probably been something like consistency
over a long period of time
yeah for this because we're looking at
longevity by definition up until the end
of life yeah you asked you began this
conversation asking what I want to look
like when I'm still having sex when I'm
90.
um
which means that you're making decisions
in the now which are very different to
if you only have a five year or a 10
year or even a 20 year timeline to what
you do you know you're training protocol
which the risk to reward it may be fun
to do this particular training style it
may be but what's the injury risk and
what would the downstream costs of that
be in 30 40 50 years time
um
I don't have great advice for how to get
somebody there I mean I just know that
I've crossed that threshold
um
probably in the last five years
and I'm I'm really happy about it I I
really it's it's it's actually created a
much greater sense of calm in my life um
less hurried in a way yeah and also just
um less less harsh you know it used to
be that every day
I used to say this every day you have to
burn at least one match and a match for
me being burned was a physical exertion
to the point of wanting to puke
I had to do that at least once every
single day
there was no workout seven days a week
that didn't at least produce that once
um so even like if I was out on a
recovery ride I would still have to
close the ride there was a I used to
live at the top of a hill and it was a
one kilometer Hill and it would always
be a one kilometer Sprint to the death
where I was always trying to hit a PR
um or every if I went into the weight
room and the goal today was to deadlift
it was like always going to try to PR
and I mean I am so far from that
mentality today that it's it gives it
sometimes you know like I'll go in and I
just don't feel right during the warm-up
like it just doesn't feel good
and I'll say you know what I'm not I'm
going to abort the deadlift today I'm
gonna go and do some safer exercises
where the stakes are a lot lower and if
I make a mistake I'm not going to get
punished for it the way I'm going to
punished if I'm doing deadlifts and I
you know
don't have my form just right
um and so yeah you've got to be able to
play the long game I think and I I don't
know what to tell somebody to get them
there other than anchoring them to the
marginal decade because if you know what
you're training for then of course you
wouldn't take that risk right like
and and honestly I think what we have an
epidemic of is people who don't know
what they're training for
like you know if you really stop them
and ask them like are you doing this
because you want to look good on the
beach are you doing this because you
want bragging rights are you doing this
are the other guys at the gym look at
you like it's okay to say that the
answer to those questions is yes but at
least be deliberate about what you're
doing and why because if you are doing
this to look good on the beach or to
have bragging rights then you might have
to compromise some of your long-term
goals
but at some point you got to decide like
what matters the most
what sacrifices did you need to make
whilst writing this book it's been a
very long labor as far as I'm aware
there was a draft at some point that
essentially just got totally burned two
two drafts and it's not a small book I
mean it's like a
it's a it's a a big boy
um
what did you have to sacrifice as
someone that likes to get things right
likes to optimize what did you have to
sacrifice in order to well I mean I
think I I had to learn to compromise a
little bit truthfully
um you know I had a co-author I have an
editor and
I think I had to learn that sometimes
they would have a point of view that was
different from my point of view and I
had to make concessions and I actually
think that in the end those concessions
were valuable so one of the biggest
conflicts early in the writing process
um so I wrote the first version by
myself and nobody liked it right so
everybody was like this is way too
Technical and there's no story
there's no story it's just
a technical Treatise on longevity
um
and I was I really rejected their
suggestion that this book needed to have
part of me in it I was like that's going
to be that it's gonna have no
credibility it's just gonna read like
you know pop fiction garbage like well
when I look at where that book is now I
realize no it had to have part of me in
it this is partly my story and it's a
story of my patients and it's this it's
it's basically a very technical book
that is weaved together between the
stories of people and
you know there's a saying right like
never make a point without telling a
story never tell a story without making
a point I you know this is something I
really really rejected in 2016 2017 in
the first iteration of that book
um there are countless other examples of
things where I was adamant that it
needed to be done a certain way and
luckily people around me who are smarter
than me said no I don't think that's the
way to do it I think I think we need to
cut this down a lot and that's a hard
thing to do when you're writing when
you're writing you know there's this
sort of thing that's called you need to
learn to kill your babies and that's a
really hard thing to do like I had there
were chapters of that book that were
literally twice as long
and I thought they were really good and
that left on The Cutting Room floor
they're gone
um and they're better now shorter it's
okay that I didn't say everything that
needed to be said
a bunch of things that we haven't spoken
about so far today are
hate cold sunlight grounding meditation
rejuvenative practices social connection
how do you map these onto the discussion
about longevity I recently read a book
by Robin Dunbar uh friends uh sorry uh
the social brain his new one and then it
he says one of the biggest discoveries
that we've seen over the last decade has
been the unbelievable power on Health
and Longevity outcomes to having a
social group has with us
where do you fit all of this stuff in
the heat that cold the sunlight the
grounding the friends how does all of
them I mean I put them in sort of
different buckets but but I would agree
with that right I mean I think that
I mean we are evolutionarily so wired to
be social creatures and that doesn't
like I'm an introvert
but which means like I don't like really
being around that many people and I
certainly don't like being around
strangers
um but I would die if I was alone
so you know people who are introverts
don't necessarily aren't immune from
this either
um and
by the way I love playing thought
experiments right so so you know one of
the thought experiments I would play
with myself when I was sort of wrestling
with this was if you could have
everything you wanted you could achieve
everything right you could be the most
physically fit you could have the most
knowledge you could have the most cars
and race cars and race tracks and blah
blah blah
but you live alone in this planet
all of your needs are met by robots that
do everything else right so the the
robots are you know pulling the oil out
of the ground to make the gasoline for
your race cars and they're building it
and they're farming your food or
whatever whatever it is like but you're
alone like think about that existence
right like you can't fathom in existence
alone regardless of how good everything
else is in your life in fact that would
be the closest thing to hell that I
think I could ever imagine
so
we certainly know at the extreme end of
the spectrum that loneliness is an
enormous predisposing factor for suicide
right so suicide is just the most
extreme form of emotional death
um but
I I think there are a lot of people who
never get close to Suicide but who then
enter kind of the second orbit around
suicide which we would call parasuicide
so engaging in behaviors that are
ultimately Reckless enough that they
cost you your their life I mean you
would argue that smoking is parasuicide
excessive drinking is parasuicide using
dangerous illicit drugs that
unfortunately nowadays are so often
laced with fentanyl is parasuicide is
driving a strip back three series with a
V6 engine and roll cage Parry suicide I
don't think so I think it's I think
driving to the racetrack to do those
things is basically parasuicide now I
it's so funny I actually brought my
daughter to the racetrack for the first
time two weeks ago Kota uh no I went to
Harris Hill so
um I would love to bring her to CODA I
wanted to start her at Harris Hill it's
a smaller track you don't get nearly as
fast and
she was so reluctant for like a year to
come how old is she she's 14. okay and I
was like
she's like well how what happens if we
hit something and I was like well Olivia
the way they design race tracks it's
like it's anticipated that you're going
to lose control of the car sometimes so
everything is designed to minimize that
plus the cars are safe so anyway she
finally came I have a GoPro on the dash
filming us driving it is hilarious to
watch her head like moving around and
stuff because the uh you know she's
right you know what a Hans is yep yeah
so the the belts came off her Hans I
don't think my coach strapped her in
tight enough and so pretty soon she's
like you know she's still strapped in
there but she's not like I am like when
I'm in there like my Hans is like
um and I showed the video to one of my
buddies he goes she looks like one of
those monkeys they used to put on rocket
ships like just like you just see a big
helmet head like bobbling around it's
hilarious but anyway uh no I I would I
would not describe that as parasuicide I
would describe that as nor would I
describe skiing or other sort of risky
Sports I just think you have to decide
where they are within your risk behavior
um
but then you go even beyond that and I
think there's you know behaviors that
that aren't going to kill you but
they're just going to make your life so
miserable right like having horrible
relationships with people
um
that degrades the quality of your life
and
while I do think that that does shorten
your life ultimately right I do think
that there are biochemical ways that
that impact
probably through stress hormones
probably through you know greater
activation of sympathetic you know an
imbalance between sympathetic and
parasympathetic flow I think those
things absolutely do impact our immune
function our cardiovascular function all
these things
um
even if they didn't
what's the point I'm going to think
about the enjoyment of Life yeah
that we can break things down into an
objective list of metrics and how does
it impact the things that we can measure
that are going on but what's your felt
sense of life like yeah so go back to
what you said in your marginal decade
and I think most people when you ask
them about their marginal decade none of
it's in isolation it's you said picking
up grandkids being able to walk your dog
which is a companion being able to have
conversations with other people that's
the cognitive piece so I think when most
people really think about this they
can't escape the fact that their quality
of life is inextricably linked to
interaction with other people
we haven't spoken about emotional health
as an individual at the moment
um it might surprise people to think
about when you have the discussion about
longevity
you're talking
time on the planet bone density muscle
mass cardiovascular risk etc etc
what about emotional health how should
people even frame that in the discussion
that we're having
I think it has to be top I think it's
right that's right there with those
other things I don't think it's I don't
think it's something that should be
thought of as an afterthought it's uh it
matters just as much
um again you know long life with you
know poor emotional health is is
probably a curse
what rejuvenative practices do you find
best you know we 10 12 14 hours a week
of sometimes punishing sometimes
sub-punishing workouts and yeah usually
sub punishing right so call it 12 to 14
hours a week of exercise is very
important for me
um I do sauna four days a week I try to
do four days a week um session length uh
minimum 30 so so 30 to 60. at uh
196 to 200. are you taking a break but
those you must be go straight through on
that I I can I usually will go 30 and
then a quick break though 60 at 200
would be uh I've never done 60 or 200
I've done 60 at like 194. that's hard
okay right so four times a week yeah
four to five times a week and by the way
that's doubly regenerative for me or
rejuvenative depending on because like
I'm again I never do that alone right so
I'm gonna do that with a friend I'm
gonna do that with my wife yep and it's
always just an awesome time to be like
last night talking about you know my
whole my wife and I spent the whole time
talking about you know a session she had
with her therapist and how you know how
much she learned and it was just so
wonderful to have kind of backing yeah
multiple things on top it's just it's
just being able to do multiple things at
once that are both
um really beneficial
um I like rucking that's something we
didn't really talk about I don't really
lump that into my exercise bucket of
time though it is
um it is obviously a great type of
exercise but because of the way that I'm
doing it which is I'm not taking any
Electronics with me and I'm not
multitasking when I do it it really is
just as much about my brain as it is my
body so rucking of course just for folks
who don't know it's basically walking
around with a very heavy backpack
so you know sweet spot is about a third
of your body weight
um and uh you know so I'll go and do
about three three and a half miles with
as many Hills as I can find and not I'm
not taking anything like I don't I'm not
listening to podcasts or books or
anything I don't have my phone with me
so it's really just
uh something that's unusual for me
because usually I mean they're working
or if I'm exercising in the gym I'm
listening to music if I'm on my bike
there's always multiple stimulus going
on yeah I'm listening to a podcast or
something like that but here it's truly
just observing thoughts
what's your divisive choice for rook and
goruck yes absolutely love those guys is
that
do they do anything that isn't because
they do the thing that's like a big
penis coming out of your back where you
can literally plate load it right I'm
gonna guess you use a more I have a pack
so there's a there's a there's an actual
pack that has pockets in it so you drop
the plates in it cool and you've got
what's like 60 pounds seven pounds in
there 60 and I have several packs so I
have one my wife has one we have one for
Anytime friends come over and I've just
got like we've got tons of weight so
away we go oh here we go yeah so it's
like I like to do wrecking Wrecking
meetings with friends okay yeah cool so
you have a cold plunge love that as well
what are you aiming to hit per week then
um again it depends uh
probably also about four times a week
um and again that's something I like
doing with my wife even though she's
tiny she can she can actually take the
cold almost as much as I can I have a
lot more insulation than she does worse
for conversation than a sauna perhaps
yeah not as much the usually the
conversation there is how much longer
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay um
and and then truthfully I think the most
sort of rejuvenating practice is playing
like I I'm really lucky because I have
my daughter doesn't like to play as much
but we still play like we you know we
play volleyball she loves volleyball so
anytime I can be out on the court with
her playing volleyball I'm teaching her
how to drive stick so that's something
that she loves doing she'll be like that
can we go and drive and it's like yep
get in the pickup truck go to the
parking lot and you know making her
start on steep hills and stuff like that
is awesome and my boys are eight and
five and so all they do is play and so I
get to play every single day get down on
the ground you're probably on the ground
grass playing Lego jumping on a
trampoline goofing off I like doing Lego
myself that's another Super that's a
super enjoyable thing for me to do what
is you I saw did you post something
saying that shares of Lego had increased
by 25 at some point and your wife had
accused you of being single-handedly
responsible contributing to it you moved
the Lego Market yeah yeah yeah wow um I
got sent by a very good friend Tim
Bishop from Australia uh a Coliseum Lego
set yeah this is one of the three
biggest Lego sets yeah so he sent me
this uh which is one of the four so the
yeah look tell me what's the first
biggest the first biggest I think sucks
it's the world map
lame it's so lame right second third uh
second is the Eiffel Tower
that's the new Eiffel Tower
there was an old one right the new one
is really cool have you done that one uh
we have not my boys want it okay my boys
are just finishing the Titanic which is
the third largest and the Coliseum is
the fourth right and it's funny my boys
I was putting them to bed last night and
we were playing the rank order game
which one would you want and I I said
that I think that I think the coolest is
the Titanic followed by the Coliseum
okay well I've got that have you done it
yet no I haven't even opened it up
um Tim sent it to me with the a letter
about uh the man on the stadium floor is
it yeah the Teddy Roosevelt question
yeah uh which was very meaningful yeah
and he shipped the thing from Australia
or maybe he hasn't yeah he must have
done because it had the note in it God
yes I shipped it across the planet you
can do it I mean I find that I I love
doing Lego I do the my favorite of the
Technic cars so I have all of them okay
um do you do this I'm gonna get because
one of the other things that I had Kelly
Star on the show yesterday you know
Monday this week
and there's this big movement at the
moment for being on the ground yeah
spending as much time hips below knees
as possible do you consider that as well
are you legoing no I I do Lego on a
table I was like it's so complicated
like I have I have multiple plates laid
out with all the different pieces and so
your workstation needs to be optimized
yeah I can tell that you're surgical
with your Lego creation
um but my you play on the floor with
kids because kids play on the floor
understood yeah and that's also
something that factors into how you
think about this last decade of your
life which is if you want to play with
grandkids
and that's why by the way I think the
Step Up is an amazing exercise the Step
Up is the movement that tells you you
can get up off the floor
um
tell you one thing I haven't brought it
up yet today I've been playing around
with a Vitruvian at home which is kind
of like a tonal it's like magnetic Drive
training thing and they they sent me one
two or three months ago this thing's so
much [__] fun it's so cool
um so you can imagine a like a stepper
like one of those Reebok things that
ladies in Aerobic class would use a
little bit bigger than that flat on the
ground magnetic drive two cables that
come out of it two nylon cables tons of
attachments that go in you can belt
squat by slotting something between the
two they can be a long bar that goes
between the two you can use it all these
different bits there's a bench as well
and the bench has got one uh leg is
shorter than the other so it can go flat
or you can flip it and then it's an
incline
um
it's so much but is it working is it
it's magnetic yeah okay yeah yeah so you
can have time and attention uh if you
start to fail on a rep it'll it'll dial
the weight back and then as you get to
the top it'll turn it back on yeah so it
can do eccentric only training yeah and
it goes up to 440 pounds of of weight
and doing step ups with that or doing my
favorite movement with that is a front
foot elevated split squat so putting up
onto that handles in either hand
so much [__] fun and it feels so how
much room does it take up not just
literally just this the size of a
like the Reebok step yeah that's it and
there's no more room to eat how much are
they three grand
and uh three three and a half and if you
get like the uh
looks sweet of additional things the
nicer handles the belt squat Etc you're
probably looking at all in including
shipping probably like under three and a
half something like that they're not a
sponsor on the show but they sent me
this thing and if you had a
thousand square foot 500 square foot
apartment in New York you could slide it
but it's got little wheels on it put it
up against a wall it would take up no
room and do this thing [__] crushes
you it absolutely destroys you
um
and there's the app as well that they've
done something else I thought was really
cool you can
do not only individual workouts where
there's a video and the person does it
and it tells the machine what you're
doing and it gives you time in between
for rest or to change the things over
and you change it over with the guy or
the girl um but it can do entire
programs where it pings you and says you
need to do lower body today and then you
press it and then away you go
I trained in the gym for nearly 20 years
now and this thing's really fun and I
really really enjoyed the variation that
it's added into my training so you know
thinking about Lego thinking about
getting down on the ground thinking
about stuff like
10 years ago if you'd said oh you're
going to love box step-ups so [__] off
I'm not going to enjoy box step-ups uh
all of these different training
modalities are great pickleball's great
I'm really enjoying and I think that you
mentioned it as well like transitioning
the
um goals that you've got yeah what are
my aims what are my priorities here uh
the first time I spoke to David Sinclair
like I said four years ago just after
the first time he did Rogan and I
thought this is really interesting I
learned about anime and all this [__]
and I went to go and see him and it
still sounded to me a lot the longevity
movement generally
um halfway between like something for
other people because I was made of
rubber and magic and 30 years old uh and
uh just it was it was sitting over there
whereas now it very much feels like I
need to I really need to take
heed of this it's not just about
learning it and teaching it to other
people it's like okay [__] like how do I
start to integrate this into my life and
I think that a lot of more people are
feeling that as well now
yeah well I mean I the the interesting
thing is the relationship between the
age of an individual and when they start
to pay attention to these things and
the younger you are the greater your
advantage in terms of the compounding
benefit of the changes so this is all
about you know
daily practice right this is all about
day in and day out adhering to these
things but the drawback of being young
is that marginal decade is a very
abstract concept less motivating yeah so
it's harder for you to stay focused on a
goal that's so far away
conversely when you look at people in
their 60s
they've they're already on the downside
they've they've watched their parents go
through this they've they've watched
people live and die through horrible
marginal decades they have all the
motivation in the world if we want to
use that word
they just have less room to alter the
course if they're really far off
so
I I've I've I'll never know what this
perfect time is to to begin other than
right now
you know the perfect time was yesterday
the next best time is today
um but it's it's always interesting to
observe that difference between the
extremes of age did you become
chronically aware of your own mortality
as you went to the beginning of your 30s
I think it's just it's the first time
where warm-ups take a little bit longer
where hangovers failed they never felt
that good but they feel start to feel
really really rough
um and it does it it's a very strange
situation especially as a guy especially
as a guy who's taken a lot of pride in
the way he moves or looks or his
physique and stuff to start to kind of
at the top of a roller coaster you go oh
this isn't going up anymore I'm kind of
weightless at the top and maybe this is
the biggest or the fittest or the
strongest that I'm ever going to be uh
and realizing that it's like oh [__] I
need to I need to think more carefully
about this
um but another side you know when we're
talking about motivating young people to
consider in your 20s or whatever to
think about longevity
one of the prescriptions that you've got
is you have like a 15 to 30 minute
window for sleeping for wake and like
try and lock that in
if you do that throughout your 20s
you're not going to have a massive
number of Life Experiences now that
being said it's not a prescription
you're still fine for you to go and
travel and change time zones and all the
rest of it but there is a degree of like
look just go and live life and perhaps
part of the reason that you're able to
deal with that when you're younger is
that it is more indicative of the kind
of lifestyle that you're going to live
and then as you do get a little bit
older things are going to be routinized
kids will be need to be taken to school
work will require you to be at a place
at a particular time you can't just piss
off and do a season in Ibiza or you know
like move to Hawaii for a couple of
months or whatever right
um and I think I like that I like the
journey I really enjoy the The Arc that
I can feel happening with my training
with my fitness
um with the way that I look at stuff and
thankfully your friends grow with you
and you tend to be friends with people
that are your age so you're all thinking
about the same things you're all
thinking about like dude you like if you
drink the wrong amount of water on the
night time do you have to get up and go
to the bathroom in the middle of the
night like [__] yeah like right dude I
feel like we need to do a bit of
research on this you know what I mean
yeah
Peter I really appreciate you I really
appreciate your work I think the book's
fantastic it's been a labor of love for
[__] over half a decade for you uh if
people want to check out all of the
stuff that you do where should they go
um I think the everything is under my
peter attia MD so the website we have a
newsletter that comes out every Sunday
that's um I think pretty good
um and then the podcast the drive
thanks Peter thanks Chris what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign